all right welcome everybody my name is
Joe Merlot we're gonna go through real
quick some of the install instructions
and then we'll get through and start
doing some things most of you have
probably done the install instructions
already so I'm just gonna cover those
briefly a couple tools we want to have
on our systems I tend to prefer using a
tool called Conda to help me do package
management some specific libraries that
we're going to install we'll walk
through those we'll go through how we
test for installation and talk a little
bit about why we're doing things with
this way mean some steps may say install
thus and turns out you already have it
installed so you may not have to do that
for this tutorial I highly recommend
using Conda as a package manager because
there are some libraries that are kind
of sucked into this process that are not
necessarily Python libraries so some
Python package managers may not be real
good for this Conda has a virtual
environment manager to help manage your
virtual environments and we'll talk a
bit about what that means the material
for this has been tested using Conda but
it has not been tested with pip it has
not been tested with virtual in etc if
you already have Conda installed you can
test that if not the instruction should
walk you through it for this course
material we're using python version 3
dot and you say python equals three and
one of the commands will do in a minute
it'll give you the latest version of
python from my experience the most
common problem that i see when people
start to do this is they they miss a
step right our eyes tend to glaze over
and we miss things so if you have a
problem
scroll back check to see if you've done
all the things if not we have a set of
mentors in the room and myself we can
walk around and help you especially
during the part where we do exercises
there are a set of instructions for
doing this in Windows and Mac and Linux
you can confirm whether conda's been
installed this is high tech guys alright
next all right so let's talk a little
bit about what we're doing when we're
installing Python and some of the other
things you're gonna make a directory
called stats you're gonna change into
that directory so now you're inside that
folder and we're gonna create a virtual
environment at the bottom of this
material I have kind of a write up as to
why virtual environments important and
how they can be useful to you and I'll
leave that up to you to read it but the
the big picture for virtual environments
and why you might want to use one is
that it creates a sandbox some of you
have Python already installed in your
computers and you maybe use it for work
and you don't want to corrupt or mess up
your existing version of Python your
existing libraries that use with Python
so the virtual environment makes a
sandbox what we do goes in the sandbox
and it doesn't interfere with anything
that that happens right once we've made
a virtual environment we have to
activate it and if you've activated a
virtual environment you're gonna see
these little parenthetical off to the
side to say you're now using that
virtual environment and now using the
version of Python that you installed for
that environment and then next we can
say Conda install and you can tell it
all the libraries that you would like to
use in this case we have five main
libraries that we intend to explore all
right once you've installed those will
type Jupiter space lab and hopefully a
lab environment will open up if you do
not have one let us know and we'll get
you get you taken care of and kind of
raise your hand I'm gonna pass out some
stickies as well in a little bit all
right next we have class material it is
up on github I'll put the links back up
for those in a second you guys can go
look for that all right as we go through
the process you
see these green poster notes in the
material all the stuff I want you to do
basically stops there if you want to
keep reading you can go ahead but you
can typically stop wherever green
post-it note is for those who really
want to know more details about all of
these things at the bottom of this
lesson I have a big-picture description
of why we used virtual environments what
is Conda doing why are we using and all
that stuff and so you can scroll through
and read all of all of that content at
your leisure we're not going to go into
it all right so with that in mind I'm
gonna walk you through a little bit
about kind of how this class itself is
gonna play out and the types of things
that we want to do first off I
appreciate Pike on my family friends who
suffered through me trying to get this
material ready my company that helps to
get me here Booz Allen Hamilton the
PyCon tutorial selection committee the
mentors who are here in the room we're
gonna be helping you guys and especially
you for being willing to come out and go
through this statistics and probability
exploration with me to give you an idea
of what to expect and what not to expect
right we'll do an overview of some
probability and statistics print so it's
a tough word right it's hard English is
tough we're gonna do an overview of
probability and statistics principles
and techniques we will have some
snippets of Python code I'm going to
warn you right now the code that xiaomi
wrote for here should never be used in a
production environment the things that I
wrote are more to demo principles to
give you an idea of how things work kind
of under the hood they are not for true
statistical analysis and I'll prove it
I'll show you why there's gonna be
plenty of opportunities for you to level
up your skills we will have exercises
that you guys can walk through and we'll
give you a certain amount of time in
this tutorial to work on those myself
and the mentors will help you I will
highlight a few of the gotchas to look
out for things that you might be
experiencing as you go through this
journey on your own when you get back to
your house etc and we're gonna provide
some resources to help you continue your
learning journey when you go
what are some good books to read or were
some good things to look at etc so what
not to expect if you think this through
a typical college class is about forty
some odd hours of sitting in a lecture
hall lots of homework in between sitting
in lecture halls we have three and a
half hours and if we bring biology and
taking breaks and stuff into this story
we have about three hours right so
you're not gonna get a whole lot out of
this my hope though is that you will get
a flavor and that flavor will drive you
to go home and keep learning you are not
gonna get out of Chalmer robust
industrialized code we spoke about that
and in terms of deep dives we're not
gonna have the time so some folks may
ask some questions like hey I want to
know a little bit more about these types
of distributions and how these are
related to that we're probably not going
to have the time for a lot of that we
could have maybe conversations about
that outside of this I really want to
give you guys this nice high-level
overview in terms of logistics pair
practice is used in some tutorials
because working closely with a partner
helps you kind of identify what's going
wrong and to help each other out I'm not
gonna force that upon anyone if you want
to work with someone who sits next to
you say hey why don't we work on the
code together or why don't we work
through these exercises of pair I'll
leave that up to you and your level of
comfort we're gonna distribute out some
post-it notes for you when you get to
the end of a period of exercises you put
your post-it note at the top of your
monitor so I can look out when I see a
sea of green I know it's time to kind of
move on if you run into a problem you'll
have a red poster note that will hand
out to you you put it on your monitor
myself or the mentors will look out and
go oh red post-it red post-it and we'll
come to you right so you don't have to
do this whole embarrassing hey I got a
problem thing there will be a survey and
I'll get you the link to that later
I really want to get your feedback okay
so how do we get the most out of this
experience I love this picture and let
me zoom down so you can see it the top
and I apologize it's small font it says
how do you actually learn any new
programming concept by changing stuff
and seeing what happens
one of the cool things about python is
that you can try something run it and
see what happens you go wow that was
cool let me change this number or let me
do this thing and you run it again and
you get an instantaneous kind of
response
so I heavily encourage you play with
things when you do an exercise and you
get done a little early try and go back
and do it again to tweak something
you're gonna have questions that might
come up like hey Chalmer what if or what
will happen if we do this and I love to
hear those questions those are great I
will caveat that though with I also love
to see folks have that question in their
head and they go try it themselves
because sure I can demo it for you but
man how much fun and excitement it is to
try it and see some cool response some
people say well I don't want to break
anything I don't want to do it wrong and
that's a legit fear so I'm not gonna
minimize that but generally with Python
you're not really gonna break much and
if you do you can kind of reboot and
often if you do quote-unquote break a
thing there's gonna be some error
message and you're gonna skim it and
maybe it's confusing but you're gonna
see new words and new terms and you can
start to learn things because those
error messages as scary as they might
look will often teach you things
especially when you see them over and
over again so try not to be scared
there's a couple other things in here
and I'm not going to go through them in
the interest of time but they're there
and they talk about the psychology of
learning stuff but this quote here is
kind of neat being a programmer
basically requires you to deal with
these extended periods of feeling like a
complete [ __ ] punctuated by very brief
periods of feeling like a genius right
that's my life every day I'm standing up
here trying to teach you guys a thing
but most of my life is I don't know how
to get my code to do this thing and I
don't know why and then all of a sudden
it works and I feel like that guy on the
Titanic right and I feel great and then
my boss is like will solve this other
problem now that that's done suck okay
so let's get rolling
let's talk about statistics
all right so this is kind of the the
main meat of the thing I'm gonna
disappear behind the podium and grab
those post-its and have one of my
colleagues pass them around and then
I'll come back I'm still here
voila all right everybody gets one green
one red not one pad one green post-it
one red posted you don't know what he's
gonna do all right so let's get started
this first conversation is going to talk
about statistics right and what we can
do with that and then a little later on
we're gonna move into probability okay
our main goal right now for this first
little bit is to understand you know
some techniques for counting things to
determining what the minimum value is
maybe in a data set figure out what the
maximum value is and then we will look
at these things that we call central
tendencies that the fast version is
what's the average and we'll explore
different ways to look at that and then
we will talk about well how widely does
stuff kind of deviate from that average
is my data really spread out or not okay
let me try and blow this up a little bit
maybe okay we're gonna look at the data
and we're gonna look at these techniques
in these processes through a couple
different tools we're gonna start off
with some simple data sets just a couple
numbers so we can kind of visually see
what the thing is we will then go
through a little bit larger data set a
little more sophisticated we're gonna
have some hand developed code that's
chalmers do not use this in production
code and then I'm gonna walk you through
a couple of standard libraries that have
some functions that do what my code does
but does it way better all right to kind
of get us in the right frame of mind I'm
gonna use a I mean use that big data set
that I mentioned we'll look at it and
we'll display it on the screen in a
graph and then we're going to use tools
to kind of figure out what some of those
data points are okay by hand as it were
all right so let's pretend I'm a
manufacturing
and in every day I produce a new batch
of stuff on some days my machinery is
well tuned and the number of batches
that I produce or that the batch that I
produce has very few defects in it but
other days my machinery is starting to
fall apart things are breaking and all
of a sudden I get larger quantities of
defects so I may want to track these on
a day to day basis all right so I have
this data and it is this number of
defects I purposely kind of organized it
so it's kind of bigger numbers at the
top smaller numbers at the bottom
they're not quite sorted but so we see
some things like there's a 99 there's a
52 there's a 42 at the bottom we have
some twos and threes and fours I don't
know there's like two hundred and eight
or some some odd numbers we'll figure
that out I will warn you we're not gonna
do a deep dive into matplotlib I'm gonna
gloss over this real quick I just want
it to give you a graph but I use
matplotlib here to import some
capabilities that will enable me to make
a very basic plot I also have a tool
called the counter tool and we'll talk a
bit about it in a minute
that's gonna help me count things and
now I want to make a simple histogram a
simple graph what we're gonna do is try
and start off by making this display and
we're gonna use a tool called most
common which is found in the counter
object and you'll see how that works out
all right so I start off by taking all
of those values that I had number of
defects and I drop it into my counter
object and that's going to produce a
thing that looks like a dictionary but
it's not quite and so I call it defect
counts and then I say all right show me
the five most common values that
occurred in all of my number of defects
so we run that code and so the number
eight showed up 24 times the number six
showed up 24 times and the number seven
showed up 18 all right I mentioned that
counters look a little bit like
dictionaries there's two nuances that
you should know they have this kind of
extra method that we just saw called the
most common
that allows us to find out what are the
most common things and I can tell that I
want to see the two most common items
and it'll give me that or I can say I
want to see the five most common items
and he'll give me more right but one
other nuance that is fun is that if
you've ever played with a dictionary and
you try and access a value that doesn't
or access a key that doesn't exist your
dictionary will vomit on you and it
throws up this little error and says hey
you tried to look at something that
doesn't exist counters are cool that
they don't do that if I try to access
the number 77 which is not in my defect
count it goes that's fine and it just
gives me back a euro if I try and access
a number that does exist like an eight
it'll look into the counter I go oh
there was a 24 stored there and I'll
give me back a 24 so this is kind of
cool
and we'll take advantage of that
particular functionality in a second all
right
so I want to create a list of X values
to go on the bottom of my chart and I
want to see all of those Y values that
are in my defect count the 8th of the 24
and the 24 and and those things and I
want to store them into separate lists
so I can dump them into matplotlib so
for those who haven't seen it this is a
list comprehension syntax I'm not going
to go into it but it's very useful for
doing analysis I'm not going to talk
about these these are all just the
things that we use for matplotlib and
it's going to take all of me x values
that we just made and all of the Y
values that we made and it's going to
plot them all right and so we get this
nice little chart and a couple things
that we can see right off the bat where
are most of the things low end right
there appear to be two little spikes do
you guys remember what numbers those
spikes were at what were the most common
values 6 and 8 when we looked at the
data and I said hey I got this stuff
kind of
organised there was a big number at the
front it was a 99 and sure enough we see
there was a little spike over there by
the 99 turns out maybe that's an outlier
maybe not right okay so this visually
shows us a lot of cool things I want to
figure out how do we get to some of
these data points using code we'll start
off with using count maximum and minimum
what function do we use to count things
in Python Len write stands for length so
if I have number of defects and I drop
it into the Len function it will tell me
that I have two hundred and four data
points and you can essentially count
just about anything in python using lin
all right if i want to find the biggest
value in a set or the smallest value set
what what functions do I use Max and min
all right so let's do that let's take
number defects we'll drop it into max
drop it into min and we get that big
value of 99 and our smallest value
happen to be a to sweet all right a lot
of Statistics is basically telling you
stuff about your data how many pieces of
data do I have what is the highest thing
what's the smallest thing one of the
things that we often talk about like
what's the average grade in a class or
what's the average weight of people in
doing this thing right what's the
average of age of folks in a particular
group Python has tools to look at that
and when statisticians look at that kind
of information they typically point to
three main things mean median and mode
mean is also often referred to as
average and it's probably the one you're
most commonly associated with so I'm
gonna walk you through how we can
calculate means medians and modes using
my lousy code alright so here we'll
start off with calculating a mean if I
drop a series of values into this
particular function it will try and
figure out a what is all of the a values
added together and then it will divide
it by how
any values do we have okay do that and
so let's just use a really simple set of
values these four things the average
should be like two and a half if my math
is right and if I do this one the
average should be three right pretty
straightforward anyone want to take a
guess what the average is for our bigger
data set any thoughts
wow that's amazing well done all right
all right now I'll show you in a little
bit some other libraries that walk you
through doing means and we'll talk about
some of the benefits of using those all
right but now I basically have an idea
of kind of where is the average number
and it's somewhere in here between nine
and ten okay now let's go look at
medians so median is a little
interesting the point of medians is to
find the center most value if I've got
11 things it'll find whatever's at
position 6 if I've got five things it'll
find what it severs at position three
right it doesn't really care if it's big
little tiny whatever it just says you've
got this number of things let me find
whatever is stored in the center all
right but there's a caveat if I have an
odd number of things like 1 3 & 5 the 3
is clearly in the middle but if I have 1
3 5 & 7 what's in the middle and how we
typically solve this is we take an
average of whatever the two things are
in the center and so my code will do
that the nuance here is before you find
whatever's in the middle you need to
sort them so we're gonna sort all the
values we'll calculate how many values
we have we'll figure out what is the
midpoint and then we will return it if
we find out that there are an even
number of values we're gonna do this
thing where we we average we find out
there's an odd number of values we just
give you the
Centerpoint all right so I'm not gonna
walk you through the code in too much
detail you can take time to look at that
if you want let's just see if it works
sure enough it gives me a two this one
remember we have to sort first so it's
going to move the 42 to the end and
it'll find whatever's between the five
and six which is a 5.5 all right and I
know this guy's already done the math in
his head right he knows what the number
of the meeting number defects it's an
eight okay so we can take an average
which you're used to we can take the
median find the middle most point mode
finds whatever shows up most frequently
all right for this library I'm also
going to use counter to help us with
this we're gonna count all the values we
will find whatever value shows up most
frequently how many times it shows up
and then we will go in using another
list comprehension and if you're not
familiar with these I highly recommend
you go figure them out because they're
really awesome we will go and say all
right the maximum number of things was
24 things showed up let's go see how
many items showed up 24 times and this
list comprehension will give me every
value that had 24 entries in my account
so let's go take a look here the number
4 is going to show up 3 times so it will
show up most frequently so we should get
back a 4 notice just a nuance here with
mode I choosing to return a list of
items because sometimes certain things
more than one thing may show up most
frequently like this list one shows up
three times five shows up three times so
I want to get both of those back so it's
going to return a list with both of the
things that showed up most frequently
the 1 and the 5 just a nuance about that
right we talk about kind of the average
most the time in our heads we tend to
think of there is only a single average
when you start talking mode you can have
bimodal or trimodal datasets where
spikes of things occur there's a book
that
kind of like for folks who are new to
statistics its headfirst statistics and
they talk about this ages for this group
of folks in this class and it's a class
for adults and children to do like
swimming together or something I don't
know and when you look at the ages the
average ages you have these very young
children and you have these older adults
and so your average age is very
different and it's split alright so
that's the thing that you'll see in many
cases with mode all right
so let's go look at the most frequent
values in number of defects it was eight
and six just like we saw earlier all
right so a couple of nuances of when we
might use these and and some of the the
benefits of using them I've got a little
table here mean you do this some of the
values and you count how many values you
have you do the math this is most
commonly used when your data kind of has
symmetry to it and it has a single trend
of one single spike the median is often
used with data that might be skewed a
little bit to one side of the or the
other and might have some outliers it's
kind of a way of dealing with the fact
that you're outliers will throw off some
of your results and then mode it's
different from some of the others
because you can actually use mode with
things that are called categorical data
and you'll hear that in statistics what
categorical data means is it doesn't
have a number value like if I had a list
of data and the data just simply said
male female or the data said you know
Part A Part B Part A Part A Part B Part
B those are all categories right and so
modes can show us what is the most
frequent part that showed up what is the
most frequent examples of things and you
don't have to have a number for them so
categorical data can be done with modes
and it's also good for things as I
mentioned that have more than one trend
all right we did a fancy histogram graph
but sometimes just having a quick
frequency table can be really useful and
so a frequency table would be something
like this where it shows hey the value
nine showed up three times the value six
showed up
WAIS it's much like that counter example
we looked at if we look at our defect
counts the frequency table is not
specific to mode it is the counts of all
your values mode is highlighting the
things that show up most frequently the
frequency table shows up the values of
all of them
notice where did it go my frequency
table it showed up that eight appeared
only once where mode is going to show me
the things that appeared most frequently
mode would give me the value nine showed
up three times or would give me the
value eight and six showed up 24 times
does that help good all right so what
I'd like you guys to do and I'm gonna
shrink this down give you guys a few
moments to kind of start to wrap your
head around some of these things I'd
like for you to calculate and you can
use my functions if you'd like they're
good enough for government work here and
go through this calculate the mean the
mode the median do account on these
things and go through the exercises and
we'll give you guys a few minutes to do
this
I want to caveat this for just a moment
though some people may not finish all
the exercises in the time allotted
that's totally fine go home reread the
material do the exercises again finish
the exercises you didn't finish that's
all good
just a little backstory here right and
I'll show you my list of books that I've
read I've read these statistics books of
various sorts over and over again and
even in the course of preparing this
particular set of material last night in
my hotel putting final touches on I was
still picking up nuances that I had not
seen before and still learning new facts
and details that had kind of escaped me
so there's a lot to cover as we get
further on in this in this conversation
so don't panic feel like oh man I didn't
get all of it I didn't captured yeah I
still go back and reread some of these
books and catch nuances so alright we'll
give you guys probably about ten minutes
or so and we'll wander around and ask to
answer questions
all right the little microphone appears
to be back I'm not gonna do the entire
exercise I'm just gonna highlight one or
two things so mean
let's see grab some of these guys right
and this was a nuance that I think Jeff
had mentioned if you have two commands
in a single cell
both of the commands will run but only
the last command will display to the
screen so if you wanted to have both of
these display you have two options you
could either put each of them mean and
median into separate cells that works
fine that works fine or you can do some
of that extra typing and you can put the
word print in here for the first one and
it will print and you can put median
values so it will print the first one
and then it will execute the second one
notice we get a slightly different
output print actually displays to the
screen median values actually execute
and is released as an output but that's
a nuance all right so let's see let's
talk about measures of dispersion how
widely spread is your data is your data
really tightly clustered or is your data
just all over the map okay you will
sometimes hear in statistical books
about things like measures of
variability how much does the data vary
or measures of spread they all
essentially mean the same thing a fast
and dirty measure of spread is simply
let's look at the minimum look at the
max and see how far apart they are all
right and so that's what this does my
data range function just says what's the
max what's the min and divide or
subtract 1 from the
and so with my little dataset 5 3 4 2 &
1 the smallest thing was a 1 the biggest
thing was a 5 and the the spread is 4
points notice with my batch defects the
smallest value is at 2 the biggest was
in 99 so my spread is 97 that's a lot
remember that 99 is potentially even an
outlier or something so here I can see
that my data is really far away from the
median and the mode and the mean right
so this may be a flag or maybe something
of interest it will depend on your data
all right a couple the downsides though
of using simple spread are the fact that
they are very susceptible to outliers
here I have two data sets that are
almost identical except for the last two
values the 8 and the 99 you would
probably say these these data sets are
pretty much the same and so when I have
this one thing with this minor outlier
man it throws everything completely out
of whack and it makes it really hard for
me to realize what to know that
essentially these data sets are
basically the same alright so how do we
get past that that's where things called
quantiles and interquartile ranges come
into play let me zoom in on this just a
smidge all right so you're gonna hear
some of these words these are the words
that that really bothered me I never
knew what they meant for a long time
a quantile is it's a cut point or a
dividing point right in a sequence of
values and those cut points will break
those values up into what we call
contiguous intervals or intervals that
but right up against each other so they
have a nice continuous flow and those
cut points are defined essentially so
that they break up all of your values
into equal probabilities the stuff in
this lower quantile has as much
probability as appearing as the stuff in
the middle
etc etc quartiles are values that cut
your data into quarters they are
essentially a quantile that breaks
things up into every 25% an inter
quartile range
is arranged between your lower quartile
in your upper quartile normally that's
between 25% and 75% although you might
see them with different values all right
so let's put this into practice and see
we got all right quantiles so again
these are kind of these cut points if I
have six values and I've got a cut point
in the middle it breaks my values into
two sections that middle and armed our
case would be the median if I have a lot
more values I have a value one in 60 to
63 and 64 65 and 70 this breaks up my
range of values into ten quantiles and
potentially if I want to kind of weed
out some of those outliers I could say I
really only care about all the things
that fit between this lower quantile and
this upper quantile and so I kind of
filter out whatever's on on each end and
that gets rid of the one it gets rid of
the 99 so let's make a function that
helps us calculate where a given
quantile falls so I make this very
simple function give it a handful of
values and tell it where you'd like your
your quantile to break and it will then
figure out in a list of values or
sequence of values where does that fall
what is the index of that point and it
allows you to get back a value from your
list or your sequence again this is not
robust code do not ever qualify this or
use this in production but it's good
enough for for what we need to do here
all right
so I've got a list of like school grades
there's ten values and I say hey I want
to find the break point whatever is in
the middle essentially trying to find a
almost a median it sorts everything
first 55 ends up at the bottom 96 at the
top and then it routes through I'm gonna
caveat this right this code was not
sophisticated enough to realize that if
I have even numbers I should take an
average between the two this is again
just to give you guys a demo if I had an
odd number of values 11 in this case
we can use that as well but again it's
not gonna be very precise all right what
if I want to find those quartiles the
25% value and the 75% value I take these
grades and I say hey look for whatever
grade is closest to 25% of this sequence
of values and give me whatever is
closest to 75% and so 67 is kind of the
lower lower bound of the lower 25% of my
students and 91 is kind of the upper
bound of the upper 25% of my students
now if I want to kind of see where my
defects break out using a variety of
percentiles like the lower 10% the lower
quarter the upper quarter 90 95 and 99 I
can do that and so the value of 4 is
right at the boundary of the lower 10%
value of 6 is at the boundary of the
lower 25% we noticed that value of 99 is
way above the 95 percentile okay so if I
were to say I only want to see stuff
between the 25 and 75 I filter out all
the lower end stuff I filter out all the
high end stuff and this is a great way
to kind of get a sense of what the
middle of the pack looks like so let's
do that we'll apply what we just created
to look at some interquartile ranges
commonly you'll see like 10 and 90 20
and 80 depends on what you need in our
case we'll have a lower quartile
boundary and upper quartile boundary and
I tell it hey here's the values we're
gonna give it's gonna use my function
quantile for a minute ago and say 75 is
my default value 25 is mine not default
or my lower boundary and let's see how
this works
it says Chalmer if you give me these 10
values 3 is roughly around 25% of the
way up and 8 is roughly 75% of the way
up
if I want to then do that math and say
how big a spread is this I just subtract
one of them from the other and we see
that 8 minus 3 is 5 so let's do that
with my batch of defects and it says hey
Chalmer if I'm only looking at 25% and
75% your range of values was only six
it's only a spread of six now that
function I created seems a little weak
because it's built in it it hardwired in
75 and 25 so let's build upon our
function a little bit and let's give
ourselves the option now of adding an
upper bound of our own choosing and a
lower bound of her own choosing okay and
so I'm gonna look at my number of
defects but this time I want to look at
everything from 10% all the way up to
90% I wanna see how big a spread that is
and here that spread is a little bit
bigger a little bit wider all right so
what are the downsides of using an inter
quartile range it seems like hey I can
kind of filter out those those outliers
that's good
interquartile ranges they only tell you
really the difference between a high
value and a low value how far apart are
they they don't really tell you how
closely they they are knit two things it
doesn't tell you how frequently those
high values occur or how frequently the
low values occur versus how frequently
this stuff in the middle occurs so we
would theoretically want a method to
more accurately measure variability and
we'll look at that in a minute
so we'll give you guys a break if people
need to walk around stretch whatever you
can do that as well spend a couple
minutes here say five walk through
calculating a simple spread calculating
some quantiles and then calculate an
inner quantile range for these numbers
and of course I'll ask questions are all
answer questions one nuance for this
second one you guys should pay attention
here we're gonna use the range function
to create a sequence of values from 200
all the way up to but not including 300
so if you've never used the range object
to create a sequence of numbers for you
we have that here this is how you would
do it all right and we'll cut you loose
when you're done put up your little
green stickies if your green sticky
still up take it down
you
awesome alright folks
so if I want to bang out a name for
quartile range for all these guys I can
say range 200 to 300 with a step of five
those are not familiar with the range
function the second value that you put
range will go all the way up to it but
it will not include that value and this
third number you can give the range
function tells you what step to take and
let's see it's calculate my inter
quartile range I want a 0.25 and 0.75
but those are the defaults so heck with
it
let's delete that and we should get back
a 50 and that sounds about right because
there's about a hundred difference
between the two all right let's talk
about something way more fun start about
variances in standard deviation all
right so there's a couple of different
techniques that we can use to evaluate
the spread of data that's a bit more
effective than simple interquartile
ranges or simple spreads interquartile
ranges is good for fast and dirty it's
very nice but variance and standard
deviation are one of the the workhorses
for a statistical evaluation one thing
that you may be tempted to say is well
if I want to get kind of figure out how
much things vary I could take the
average of you know what is I take the
average and I could subtract that from
each of my values and I give this
average difference from the mean and
that may look like it'll work but what
ends up happening is all of the things
that are above your mean and all the
things that below you mean cancel out
I'll let you guys read the details are
just gonna skip right by that let's talk
more about variances okay with the
variance we do something very similar we
have an average and then we subtract the
first value from the average the second
value from the average the third value
from the average and we square that to
get some sequence of numbers the benefit
of squaring which doesn't
happen in that previous thing that I
skimmed over is that these all end up
being positive numbers now they can't
cancel each other out because some are
positive and some are negative and so in
this case I have these three numbers 1 2
& 9 the average is a 4 I calculate
what's called the variance and I get
this number 38 and that gives me some
sense of how much or gives me a total 38
and then I divide it by 3 sorry
math is hard I divide by 3 and I get a
12 point 6 so it gives me some sense of
what the variance is and you may look it
in your head you go I don't even
understand what variance means because
how did I get a 12 point 6 to tell me
how much stuff spreads when my numbers
don't even get up to 12 I have a 1 2 and
a 9 and you're gonna tell me
quote-unquote the variance is this 12.6
thing and so summer you're sitting there
and you have this quizzical look on your
face and that's the same quizzical look
that everybody has which is why we go
one step further we use a thing called
standard deviation before I talk about
standard deviation the nuance here
though that you can get is if I were to
change these numbers and spread them out
a little further potentially my variance
may get bigger my variance gets smaller
so if I have two sets of data and one
variance is large one variance is small
the one with a larger variance is spread
out more the one with the smaller
variance is spread out less so the
number itself may not jump out at you go
that means something but numbers are
variances from separate data sets can
give you a sense of one spreads out more
than the other but again variance is
kind of this nuanced thing like people
like I don't even know that means so
well we'll do a function we'll look at
this happening and working and then
we'll move on to standard deviations all
right so I calculate this by using the
total number of values I have a function
that calculates the difference between
the means I square them I will let you
guys do this again this is not
production code this is chalmers sitting
in a hotel room
[Music]
well let's try and detect or determine
what the number the variance is for our
number of defects and we need some
bizarre number our variance is 80 and
again that means nothing to me
right I don't have a sense for what that
means because no one gets a sense some
folks thought this through and they're
like is there maybe a better way and
standard deviation is a potentially
better way and I'll show you some
examples of why to get the standard
deviation you calculate the variance and
then all you do is you take the square
root of it it's pretty straightforward
so I calculate the variance same way I
get 38 divide that by the total number
of items I get a twelve point six and I
take the square root of that and I get
three point five five and again you kind
of may be saying in your head I don't
understand what that means the nuance is
that as your standard deviation gets
bigger it means it spreads more as it
gets smaller it spreads less but and
we'll see some graphs related to this
later that standard deviation fits very
nicely on your graphs in a way that
helps you to get a good sense of how
things play out all right when we use
data sets and we calculate a standard
deviation one thing that they have found
is that on a typical kind of bell-shaped
distribution a normal distribution and a
lot of data tends to fall into that
category if I calculate the standard
deviation kind of how wide is the spread
away from the mean 65% of all of my
values are going to be within one
standard deviation I mean 95% of all my
value is gonna be within two standard
deviations and 99% will be within three
standard deviations so let me shrink
this down just a smidge so we can see
this all on the screen there all right
so I have an average I have a mean in
the middle I've got some sort of
bell-shaped curve and if I can calculate
my standard deviation right here
standard deviation above the mean and
one standard deviation below the mean
everything in this gap is going to be
65% of all
my numbers will fall right there in that
middle zone if I stretch out two
standard deviations above the mean and
two standard deviations below the mean
ninety-five percent of every one of my
numbers is going to fit nicely in that
little low grouping and if I calculate
out three standard deviations 99 percent
of stuff say well how do I use this what
does this mean well much like we use the
interquartile range to say let's drop
all the values that are 25% or below all
the values that are 75% below or above
we can use standard deviations to say I
only want to see the 99% of the values
that are closer to the mean in any of
these little outliers that are way out
there in the far corners let's ditch
those or I really want to get kind of a
little closer and I want to see a 95
percent of my values that are closest to
the mean and so standard deviations can
help us grab those when we're using
something like a normal distribution
this may not apply with other
distributions but it works quite nicely
with normal distributions these
bell-shaped curves all right see this
first picture kind of spiky the data is
fairly closely clustered on the average
this next picture a little less spiky
it's a little wider and in this case
because the graph is a little less spiky
my standard deviation happens to be
bigger and so member I mentioned that I
could be looking at two different data
sets and a standard deviation is bigger
it means that data set spreads out more
and so because this spreads out more my
stem deviation is bigger but the same
rule applies even though this spreads
out more if I want to get 99% of all my
numbers and drop off the one percent
outliers I measure out three standard
deviations and boom I've got the 99
percent that I care about all right so
I've got a fairly straightforward and
let me make sure I ran the variance
formula earlier
so I got a fairly straightforward
standard deviation calculation here it
uses my variance function that I created
earlier
does the math I have a fairly narrow
data set all the stuffs pretty close
together the mean is 5 we have another
one that's a little bit broader it goes
from 1 to 9 but the mean is also still 5
and so let's look at how these two
things calculate out the mean is 5 my
standard deviation was 1.4 this is a
little bit broader data set it still has
the same average but my standard
deviation is a bit bigger so now I can
immediately go this one is a flatter
Bell than this one potentially right all
things being equal okay how do you
interpret that what does it mean all
right the nuance here essentially is
that when you're looking at your data
and you want to kind of know I have an
average how much does just spread out on
one side or the other or both the
standard deviation is going to point you
in the right direction to say this is
really close to the mean or these are
very far from the mean and so in this
case you know my numbers start at 3 they
go to 7 they're all really tightly
clustered around the mean this one
starts at 1 it goes up to 9 they're
spread further out I can immediately
tell that there's a bigger spread
between two data sets just looking at
one data set and knowing that okay the
standard deviation is 1.4 may not tell
me a lot about that one data set but
being able to compare them is really
useful
another thing you know as that number
gets smaller and smaller it means your
your-your-your spike is a little spike
year right things are narrower things
are closer and a key role for the
standard deviation again is kind of
helping you figure out how do I get rid
of some of those outliers how do I look
at my data set and say I only want to
see this stuff that's
from like 1% all the way up to 99% and
not look at the things outside of it or
where should my cut points be to look at
just the 95 percent where should my cut
points be to look at just 65 percent of
the data and so standard deviation can
help you with that all right did that
help good let's talk about how real
Python East is calculate standard
deviations and variances and those types
of things using real Python libraries
instead of my hotel code okay we're
gonna look quickly at four different
libraries and I will highlight a gotcha
that may strike if you do not pay
attention and if you don't kind of dive
into the nuts and bolts so the four
libraries were to look at there is a
statistics library this is brand new and
python as a version 3.4 it incorporates
a sequence of statistical functions and
it comes with python so if you download
Python all by itself you've got it you
don't need to get any third-party
libraries which is quite nice we'll look
at numpy numpy allows you to build these
array objects and allows you to do very
sophistications
on these types of objects that are very
fast has techniques and tools for
integrating C and C++ libraries and
Fortran code again to get closer to the
bare metal and make your code more
efficient and more faster it has
techniques to be able to broadcast
calculations and evaluations against a
large arrays of data without having to
write for loops and stuff and it's
useful for like linear algebra and those
types of things
Sify library has a collection of
mathematical algorithms it's got some
convenient functions that are built on
top of numpy because it uses an umpire
under the hood adds a lot of power to
your Python sessions and then we'll look
at pandas which is a common data science
library does data analysis and those
types of things all right
so we'll start off by importing each of
these for some of these libraries it's
fairly common to import them with an
alias like import numpy as NP it makes
it easier to type some of the commands
you might want to use later all right
I'm gonna start off by creating a simple
numpy array and we're gonna use my
defects batch okay one of the things
that I often mention to students who are
using a new tool the new library and
they're making new data types I often
recommend to them that they do a couple
of things when you make a new object
often tell them go find out what the
heck this thing is that you just made
and so I say hey what is defects and it
says hey Chalmer defects is a numpy
array and if i've never used an umpire
array i maybe need to figure out what
that means if it's spat out and today
Chalmer you just made a list I'm pretty
familiar with lists because this is a
numpy array and I don't really know a
lot about what an umpire raised right I
might want to try and get a sense of
what types of functions or methods are
available to me so we're gonna use a
technique called tab completion and this
is really useful in jupiter notebooks I
type out defects I put a dot and I hit
tab and it brings up this list of all
the types of methods and functions that
are available to me all right there we
go
nothing like moving your laptop in the
middle of a talk okay notice this is an
alphabetical order right so it says
things like all and any and
da-da-da-da-da and there now we're going
to the B's and the seas and the DS and
this is a huge list of things that you
if you are mathematically and
statistically minded can do with a numpy
array you can't do these with lists etc
we're not going to go into the depths of
this I'm just going to kind of scroll
through get a sense there's a lot of
things here notice they do have a method
in here called STD short for standard
deviation they have a method called var
which is standard for very or short for
variance all right
I'm gonna start off simple and I'ma say
hey let's use the mean function and so
calculate mean and sure enough the
average is nine point nine six is this
fine gentleman mentioned earlier I will
caveat there is no median function
associated with an M numpy array the
numpy library has a median function and
you can drop your array into the median
function but there is no median function
that hangs off of your array which I
found very interesting as I was
researching this so we say give me the
the median and sure enough it spits out
an eight and that's quite nice if I want
to look up the variance in the standard
deviation without using chalmers crappy
code we get an eighty point eight when
we get an eight point nine awesome let's
turn to scifi I'm gonna run all four of
those mean median var and standard
deviation we get nine point nine six we
get an eight point zero eighty point
eight and eight point nine looks good
one thing you should know as I mentioned
scifi kind of rides right on top of
numpy so if I go in here and I say I
like this numpy mean method but I'm not
real sure how it works I'd like to know
more about it you can ask this question
mark and you just put the question mark
in there and they'll give you the help
file for it so that and now we have
access to all of the arguments that I
can give it I give it my array and if I
want to do certain things I can have it
change its behavior I don't know what
any of these mean write access d-type
what is all of that well I can scroll
through and it will define for me oh
here's what access means and here's what
d-type means and so I can figure some of
those things out tells me what it gives
me back it says I'm gonna give you back
this that or the other and you can kind
of get some sense of what's going on
might give you some notes as to other
things you might want to look at to see
if other types of calculations might be
useful to you that's cool
happens to be really nice and give you
some sample code if you tried to get it
to work and it failed maybe you look at
the sample code and
helps you out that way all right gives
you some caveats in certain cases this
might be slightly inaccurate buyer
beware okay
it tells you where it pulled it from and
it said hey you know what we got this
out of the numpy library and it's from
this thing called from numeric pi which
is awesome if I were to do this same
thing with Sipe I mean we see I can call
sci fi dot mean but interestingly enough
all the documentation is exactly the
same and when I get down to the bottom
sure enough it actually just calls numpy
under the hood so I said your mileage
may vary okay the statistics library
statistics library has mean median
variance and standard deviation notice
the spelling is different right they
actually call it variants instead of our
they call it st dev instead of STD and
if i run that what's wrong
my numbers are different in particular
which two numbers are different the
variance and the standard deviation here
are not the same as the ones we saw
before so let's go take a look look 81
point two and ninety point zero there's
a lot of stuff here and we had eighty
point eight and eighty point nine eight
point nine so they're different all
right
why anyone know why
yes he mentions there's a difference
between population variance or
population standard deviation and sample
variance or sample standard deviation
all right so now that our heads explode
go take a look what that means when you
calculate a what's called a population
standard deviation you are looking at
the amount of dispersion for an entire
population and we use a particular
formula for that this formula we take
the difference from the mean for every
one of our values take the square we
divide by N and we then take the square
root so n is this denominator in this
case for population standard deviation
the N is a larger denominator than the
next example we'll look at alright and
for your convenience and later reading I
spell out what each of the symbols is
and why they're there
let's go look at a sample standard
deviation a sample standard deviation
it's just a sample that estimates what
your deviation for a bigger population
should be if we take a random sample out
of that bigger population and it uses a
slightly different variant value as the
denominator and minus 1 because n minus
1 is smaller than n the size of this
standard deviation tends to be a little
bigger than 4 populations all right so
when do we use population versus sample
we tend to use the population when we
know the entire population we have all
of the data in our hands we use the
sample version if we are looking at a
subset of a much bigger group of folks
so if I'm a teacher and I have 25
students and I have all 25 grades I can
use the population because I know
everybody's grades if I am looking
potentially at my students grades as
some sort of a sample of the grades
across the school or across the school
district I don't have all the grades for
the the larger population I just have my
sample
to use the sample standard deviation
alright another example if I'm a
researcher and I'm looking at the
relationship between women exercise and
blood pressure right I might use a
sample standard deviation because I only
have a subset of folks that I polled or
surveyed or researched on I don't have
all the folks in the world right so
that's why we have this difference
because that silly denominator at the
bottom is off by a smidge because we're
either looking at a sampler looking at a
population all right the numbers are
typically very very close together if
you're doing comparisons one to another
but use the same formula your
comparisons will give you an order of
magnitude difference all right if you
were in a competition like a data
science competition and you need to have
the right answer you may want to choose
the right function all right so let's go
look at one last example this is the
pandas library and it has mean median
var standard deviation notice they went
back to this kind of spelling of var and
STD let's run these guys it uses that
same version of variance and standard
deviation that the statistics library
did okay all right so just a nuance be
aware that it happens oh sweet
for those who don't know pandas in this
library allows you to create a set of
data and I take a list I drop it into
this series function and I asked by then
what do I get back
PD I say hey you have a serious and you
okay so what is a series a series
essentially is a column in a data set
you can imagine a series being like a
column in an Excel spreadsheet
so it takes this list of things and
throws it into a column and say what
does that look like in real-world
defects PD it out and so it says hey row
zero had a ninety nine in it row one
head of fifty-two row two how 242 and
it's got all 204 pieces of data
this is not a panda's class but with a
panda series you've got all sorts of
capabilities like you can do
aggregations and you can do groupings
and you can calculate means and medians
and on all sorts of other things there's
about two hundred and twenty four
different types of things you can do to
a Panda series to help you do your data
analysis you can break it up by
quantiles they have a whole library for
helping you with a whole module for
helping with quantiles and stuff it's a
lot of cool things all right
did that help okay two more questions go
so what if your data set for example
doesn't fall into kind of a nice normal
bell-shaped curve all right so that's
that's a really good question that I do
not know the answer to of how well your
data needs to fit in in the normal the
normal distribution for that to work
well I don't know if Allen has any
insight into that the question
essentially is yeah there's lots of
curves but the question was when you
have a data set if it's not necessarily
a nice bell curve and I try and do a
standard deviation how easy is it to
basically shoot myself in the foot right
if if my data doesn't fit a normal curve
is my stand deviation just gonna give me
really wonky answers
sure
so that is one of those nuances that
regularly using these tools and reading
about it again this is a three hour
class right right diving into this one
of the great things that you'll see when
you start looking at research papers
where people are using statistics to
prove a point is they use statistics
incorrectly and the point they're trying
to prove is not what the data really
shows right and it's not because
necessarily that they're being malicious
just because they're trying to apply a
thing you know round peg into a square
hole kind of a thing and that just
doesn't work so it takes time it takes
effort to dive into this research to
figure it out I will show you some of
the things that are available to us in
some of the tools like Syfy and just it
is mind-blowing the number of options
that we have available to us and so that
would play into kind of your question
yeah you had a question too
all right so if a standard deviation is
larger it tends to be sample if it is
smaller it used population so let's go
back and look well if I dump the same
data set and I'm gonna get rid of this
guy clear output if I have the exact
same data set which I do i I'm using
num defects and I drop it into sy PI I
get a slightly smaller value then I got
and I put it into the statistic library
so a smaller value means a library is
using population standard deviation a
larger value means is being sample but
having said all of that there are ways
to tell the library to do the thing that
you want so let's take a quick look at
that
[Music]
in the SyFy library for standard
deviation they have a thing called this
Delta degrees of freedom and it
identifies the divisor that you want to
use and so you can have n minus
something then the normal is n minus 1
right the default that they use is 0 so
if I needed sy PI to do the reverse of
what it normally does I can simply go
into the function and I can set this
degrees of freedom to be one versus zero
which is the default all right so again
it's just a matter of you need to know
that's there you need to know it's kind
of a problem that you have to kind of
answer so alright let's see what else we
got I think in the interest of time holy
cow how did the day go by this quickly
we're gonna skip the exercises here's a
list of cool books and I start from the
lower end of the scale to the higher end
of the scale my first book I ever read
on stats outside of high school was this
cartoon guide it was a low-pressure
guide to statistics the cover is way
more than we're gonna cover in these
three hours the manga guide I got for my
kid he liked it headfirst statistics by
O'Reilly is a book that spells things
out in a way that I find to be really
really useful naked statistics is a
little less about how one does it and
the maths and more about oh my gosh how
do you not do it wrong and he talks
about a lot of good kind of case studies
and examples of people using statistics
and the pros and cons he's very light on
the math more on the this is awesome
statistic nough so this is a great read
statistic in a nutshell that's fairly
dense it's a good reference book I like
it because it puts all the stuff in a
small amount of space but I found that
had I read it before I read maybe
headfirst or even the manga guide that
might have been a little too intense for
me think stats think Python and think
bays are great and for those who don't
know
here he wrote them and this one is a
little walking if you go to Amazon you
look at the cover of this you're like oh
my gosh but it is very compact and it
spells out a thing called Bayes theorem
and it spells it out in a way that's
kind of visual and it was quite nice
alright and for the record mr. Allen who
literally wrote the book yesterday we're
talking to like hey do you want a mentor
in your class and I'm like yes okay so
he's judging me by the way all right
thanks so let's move on to the next
thing and let's cover this let's go
through this we're gonna shift gears
we're gonna talk about probability now
the likelihood of something happened
we're gonna figure out how we can
calculate the probability of something
happening we will explore probabilities
using we call Venn diagrams we explore
probabilities using probability trees
and we will talk about the principles
behind the law of total probability and
behind Bayes theorem and we'll see a
couple of examples of that all right I
like the definition from Sarah in
statistics and that she'll probability
tells us how often something is likely
to occur if we repeat an experiment so
let's expand our understanding of
probability with a couple of definitions
you'll hear reference such a thing
called trials or experiments or
observations a trial is some event where
you don't yet know the outcome trials
can be crazy easy I'm gonna flip a coin
I'm gonna roll a dice or it could be
someone has a low birth weight will they
graduate from college 22 years later
sample space is essentially all of the
possible outcomes of a trial so I have a
six-sided die I roll it all the possible
outcomes are one two three four five and
six
say I dropped four coins in a bag I've
got a quarter a dime nickel and a penny
if I draw one of those out my sample
space will be quarter dime nickel and
penny an event is the actual outcome of
a trial events could essentially be
singles or could be groups of things we
will often designate an exam an event
with an e so if I roll a die and my
event is that I get a 1 on my die II
would be this set with 1 in it if I want
to specify that my event is that I get
an even number my e would be a 2 a 4 or
6 when I roll that die so you can have
more than one thing in your event now
I'm going to calculate a probability
this is pretty straightforward
I take how many elements are in my event
divide that by how many elements are in
the sample space and I get the
probability so the probability of
rolling a 1 on a six-sided die is 1/6
and that math turns out to be like 0.16
or something so let's throw together a
pretty straightforward function that
help us do this for those who do not
play D&D in those types of games a d6
means that your die has six sides a d8
means it has eight sides so let's make a
real quick function that returns a one
on a d6 and so I would calculate 1/6 and
I get back sure enough to do 0.16 and
that's crazy limited you would never
want to write multiple functions for
every single case so maybe we want to
expand this a little bit make our
probability function better able to
handle a large sample size or better
able to handle an event so I set my
count to be 1 and I divide it by the
sample size all right
so if my event was I roll a 4 on a
six-sided die the problem
before showing up is this the astute
observer though goes wait wait Joe Murr
we dumped in event but we never actually
used it that's screwy let's go fix that
alright if my event is composed of more
than one thing I want to determine if I
get a 2 a 4 or 6 we need to have a way
to determine that all right so I'm gonna
make a small list let's say my event is
I roll less than a for a roll one two or
three on my die I start off with saying
hey let me check did trauma just give me
a list or a tuple or did to give me a
single value if he gave me a list we'll
count how many events are in it one two
three and we'll use that to do the math
if he gives me a single item then we'll
just call it one it's all good all right
so one thing that we often do in in in
Python is alias things maybe give them
shorter names I do not want to type
probability a lot so I'm going to give
that function a new name called P so
it'll make it easier to type stuff so if
I have a six-sided die I have six items
in my sample space and I'm looking for
two the probability is 0.16 on the other
hand if I am curious like what what is
the probability of getting a four or
five or a six out of a sample space with
six items that's 1/2 if I'm looking for
odd numbers on a six-sided die one three
and five again I have a 50% chance of
getting an odd number already picking
out how many items are in a six-sided
dies pretty straightforward but when
things start to get a little more
complicated
that's where Venn diagrams come in and
you guys have probably all seen these we
use these to represent elements in your
sample space using very simple pictures
so I'm going to show you a reference
of rolling the odd numbers on a d-10 all
right so I've got a d-10 it is fairly
common in Venn diagram land to put some
sort of a rectangle and that rectangle
represents all the possible values that
you could have it is also fairly common
to draw some sort of an oval or
something or a circle to show the things
that you really care about and in this
case I only care about odd numbers and I
go ahead and I label those one three
five seven and nine I meticulously went
ahead and said everything outside of
that oval is all the other stuff I'd do
that for clarity but most of the time we
don't bother right it is presumed or
assumed that everything the rectangle is
all the other stuff if I need more than
one oval to represent two kind of
related events that I care about I can
put more than one oval we'll see that in
a bit make sure that miss any of the
things okay I'm gonna have you guys go
through your little notebooks etc
sketch out a couple of simple Venn
diagrams you don't have to make them
huge or anything wrap your head around
this idea so this first one for example
we're gonna have one thing that we care
about out of a list of twenty items on a
d20 and then I would like you to do is
put together some Python code that
calculates the probability of getting
one on a d20
this next event is a little bigger I'm
looking at just the odd items on a d-10
I've got an example I want you to
consider what would we put together to
represent I think it's all of the Oh
picking a single ace out of a deck of 52
cards right and so write some code to do
that you have to figure out what your
event space looks like or your your your
event looks like and what your sample
space looks like so spend a few minutes
do that and put your green stickies up
when you get done there's about five or
six I think what we'll do is we'll give
this
out seven minutes and then we'll roll on
so I'm gonna set a timer seven minutes
got about two minutes left
none of us is walking out of this room a
guru
thing is though he walked into the room
a guru he had a leg up on all of us
23 seconds
all right
so let's take a quick look at this I'll
look at the one that they kind of raised
the most questions numerous people asked
about this so P say I have 52 cards in
my sample space and I have four items in
my event number of people typed in 52
comma 4
our code is not yet sophisticated enough
to deal with that our code box what we
need in our code at the moment is to put
in a list of items right so you know and
an ace of clubs a ace of hearts an ace
of spades typing is a horrible thing in
front of people and an ace of diamonds
right they say hey it's about a 7%
chance of getting an ace out of a 52
card deck right if I were to type in a 4
get a much lower percentage and the
reason being if we go back and look at
the code the code said if it's a list
tell me how many elements on the list if
it's just a number
and we're gonna consider that to be a 1
so we've discovered a kind of weakness
in the code like hey this this doesn't
quite play nice let's go fix that
alright but the long story short of
these problems here and these are kind
of one-dimensional saw problems is
what's the size of my sample space and
how many elements are in my event space
all right so let's go look at our code
to do that though we kind of want to
expand on a few other things and then
we'll get there let's talk about
exclusive events and intersections most
of what we looked at are just very
simple Venn diagrams a little circle
with a certain number of things in it
there are some cases though where as I
potentially try to create a Venn diagram
I might notice that wait I'm looking at
maybe two different types of things and
trying to lump them together in my event
for an example say I had a D 10 dice and
one another probability of rolling an
even
so I have ten sides evens are two four
six eight and ten that's five so that's
50 percent chance of getting an even
chance of getting an odd is also 50% so
the chance of getting either an even or
nod is guarantee if I roll my dice I
will get either an even or odd and so I
can very nicely add these two things
together and boom I can calculate what
are the odds of getting or what is the
probability of getting an even or odd so
yes I have my little odd circle my
little even circle and there's a total
of 10 things in it my space has got 10
things so it's all good but what happens
if I do something slightly different
what is my probability of getting
something that is greater than a 5 when
I roll that 10-sided dice I have a 6 7 8
9 or 10 what is my probability of
getting a number that is even 2 4 6 8 or
10 my sample space is 1 through 10
notice greater than 5 and even have
these kind of overlapping spots where 6
8 and 10 fall into both of those ovals
if my probability getting greater than a
5 is 50% my probability getting even is
50% and I add those together that answer
is not right it would say that I have a
probability of getting or I have a
guaranteed probability getting one of
those two things and we know that's not
quite true
the correct answer of getting either
greater than 5 or even is actually about
0.7 I think use the word about and it's
quite literally exact right I have 7
things in this kind of conjoined event 1
2 3 4 5 6 7
my total sample space is 10 so 7 divided
by 10 is point 7 so what went wrong
our original kind of let's add these two
things together ignored unfortunately
the fact that there's a little bit of
overlap so we have this very cool
formula that allows us to account
overlap I have the number of things in
one events the number of things in a
second event and if there's any over a
PI just subtract out how many things
overlap so I don't double count that
ensures that I single count those divide
that by the sample space and I get the
Union or the or of a and B so that's
generic for me you notice I have this
kind of u-shaped thing and I've got this
fun of upside down you the upside down
you means the intersection where things
overlap sometimes you'll see that
referred to as a cap so the number of
things that are intersected between a
and B this U stands for Union it's kind
of an or this is the number of things
that are included in a or B all right so
sure enough we do the math greater than
a5 is a 50% chance there are five
elements there odd is five elements
there's an overlap of three we do the
math we get 7 over 10 okay so let's
start to explore this in practice we use
my little Python probability function
I've put in anything that's greater than
a 5 anything that's even and we subtract
manually the things that we know overlap
and let's get an answer and sure enough
we get point 7 so what's the probability
of drawing a single red card from a
standard deck or drawing a king well if
I were to put that into my probability
function we would see very quickly that
this would just suck because I'd have to
type out this big giant list with ace of
diamonds 2 of diamonds three diamonds
four diamonds
etc and nobody wants to type that that's
the lame so let's tweak our probability
function to say my sample size is maybe
52 cards my event could be a single
element or if I already know how big the
event is I can give it the event size
there are 26 red cards
just say that the event size is 26 and
then we add a little nuance in here it
says hey if event size is a list count
how many things are in the list so we
still have that functionality if event
size is an integer just use that as my
count so we used a four before right all
right so let's run this boom probability
of a red card or a king
there are 26 red cards in a standard
deck there are four kings in a standard
deck two of those kings are red and
let's go take a look at the answer
before we get to the answer though sure
enough with 26 red cards out of 52 I
have a 50% chance of getting a red card
with four Kings out of a deck I have a
point seven chance of getting a king but
that little bit of overlap that we kind
of have to suck out of there
that's 0.3 and I get an answer of there
we go my chances of getting either a red
card or a king are point five two it's a
little bit above half which is what we
expect so what's the probability of
drawing a red card or getting a face
card a king a queen or a jack well how
many king queens and Jack's are there in
a standard deck how many Jack's queens
and kings twelve all right so I say hey
I've got twelve here there's 26 red
cards
how many Jack's kings and queens are red
six so I want to get rid of those cuz we
do not want to double count them and
sure enough it's a little bit higher
because now we're looking at a few extra
cards right now you might say but Homer
why do I want to do all this math and
write all this code because if we think
about it all I need to know is how many
Reds are there how many face cards are
there and take away how many duplicates
and they get 32 so I can actually just
say my sample space
my at my event space is 32 cards are
either red or their kings queens and
Jack's and so I don't necessarily have
to do this if I can kind of do it in my
head or do it manually you just got to
make sure that you get event a event B
and you eliminate that duplicate and
boom we get the same value awesome so
I'm gonna for those who don't know PyCon
has open spaces where people can gather
with folks who do things that they like
to do and one of those open spaces is
board gaming alright so here's a board
gaming example I have three games I have
pandemic
I have Clank and I have Carcassonne and
in my board gaming group we have a
number of folks who play pandemic a
number of folks who play Carcassonne the
front nca ssin of this french word is
probably mangled by me my apologies and
then we have Clank some of these folks
happen to be players of pandemic and
Carcassonne some of them play Clank and
Carcassonne I have no duplicates or
overlap between these two games now
everybody in this oval this 12 and this
6 they're all part of a group so there's
actually 18 people in this group this
group has how many folks in the big
circle 16 plus 26 and then the Clank
group has how many people in it 12 right
when I was putting this example together
in my head I kept forgetting that these
six folks were with these six folks and
so my math was always wrong it's very
annoying
that's why I pointed out pandemic folks
there's 18 of them there are 12 clankers
but some of them play more than one game
alright so what is the probability of
finding a pandemic player in my board
gaming group who is also a Carcassonne
player okay well there's 18 of the
pandemic errs there's 26 carcass owners
and then there's this nice little
overlap of six we do the math and about
86% of my board gamers play those two
games but again if I don't want to type
all this nonsense as long as I do the
math eighteen plus twenty six minus six
gives me a 34 we're all good all right
there we go and the math failed epically
for some reason why did that fail
[Music]
eighteen plus twenty-six is my event
size is 36 that didn't work either 18 is
26-6 18 plus 26 is what 38
this is awesome
I'm gonna come back to this this is
great all right
based on the fact that the code may be
horribly wrong in some incredibly
awesome way we're just gonna skip those
exercises and move on let's talk about
conditionals all right
during the next break I'll take a look
at that and try and figure out what
where my math and all of that stuff went
awry all right let's talk about
conditionals because this is going to
lead to some fun stuff one of the things
that we really want to do when we start
looking at probabilities is not just
know when things kind of overlap but we
want to understand if one thing occurs
what is the probability that something
else is going to occur if I exhibit
certain symptoms COFF COFF HAC HAC
sniffle sniffle what is the probability
that I have a cold versus I have the
where's the probability of I have the
flu
or the probability that if I have a
tummy ache and some cough cough that I
might have food poisoning or something
right so if you have one condition what
is the probability that you have
something else when we talk about
probabilities we often hear the word
given so if I know that a particular
card is black what is the probability if
I'm given that it is black what is the
probability that it is also a king so I
take a card out of a deck and I say it's
black you can tell me what the
probability is that it happens to be a
king if I tell you I rolled a 10 sided
die and the number came back and it was
a an even number you can tell me the
probability that it was a 10 to help us
do that Venn diagram sometimes break
down a little bit so a really useful
feature a really useful thing that
people will point to is this idea of a
probability tree so for example I have a
deck of cards
they have 52 cards total some of them
are black some of them are red
I know that 26 out of 52 are black 26
out of 52
are red if I tell you that a particular
card is black and I want to know what is
the probability that it is a king I know
that out of all of my black cards I have
some that are kings and some that are
not Kings there are two black kings so
there's two out of 26 right and there
are 24 out of 26 that are not Kings so
there's 26 black items and they kind of
fall out in this way same thing with red
Kings
a couple of things we haven't talked
about kind of levels on the probability
tree so we have one level of my
probability tree we have a second level
with any set of branches here or a set
of branches here the math always has to
add up so that the total probability on
that set of branches is one so for
example two out of 26 plus 24 out of 26
is one right 26 out of 52 plus 26 out of
52 you add that up you get one you can
have more than two branches if you play
roulette you'll know that the squares on
a roulette table are red they are black
and there's two of them thrown in there
for good measure that are green so I
could have a roulette table probability
tree that might say black square red
square green square I could have three
branches but nonetheless the
probabilities will all add up to be one
on any individual level with a grouping
of branches okay
to solve kind of across a single branch
to figure out what is the probability of
getting to the end of a branch you
multiply the probabilities together so
if I want to say I have a deck of cards
what is the probability that I will have
a black King I multiply 26 over 52 by 2
over 26 and that will tell me the
probability that I'm holding one of the
two black Kings so 26 over 52 times 2
over 26 and I have a
roughly 3% 4% chance of holding a black
king and so if 52 items
26 multiply that by 26 and 2 I get this
now the rest of the branches play out
the same way black and not a king red
and a king red and not a king the cool
thing is the probabilities at the end of
each of the branches the probability is
way out here three percent three percent
and then like 47 and 47 they all add up
to be one as well so 46 percent it's
about 3 or 4 percent another 46 and so
when we add this up and we round it
because you know math being hard the
total probability for any single branch
when you add them all up is a total of 1
and that makes sense right ok now when
we draw a probability trees sometimes we
throw out generic probability trees that
other one was kind of specific King not
King so you'll see this kind of
nomenclature and syntax if I care about
all the elements in a group called be
anything that's not in that group you'll
often see it referred to as B prime you
might also see tilde B it just means
anything that's not B so here
probability that I get a B probability
that I don't get B this is B this is not
B there's an A up there not a a and not
a shrink this down a little bit all
right right so you'll see B prime a
prime you'll also see this nomenclature
here that nomenclature is read in the
following way
probability of a given B so what is the
probability that a get an A given that
I'm on the B branch is essentially
that means here what is the probability
again today if I'm on the not be branch
for the B prime branch right so
probability they given be given not be
okay and all that spelled out in the
text all that leads us to a formula if I
want to know what is the probability
that I get an A if I'm given a B I can
calculate for the union of a and B or
the intersection of a and B and then
divide that by B if we pull out our
algebra hats and we spin that around the
probability of A or B is the probability
of a given B times B say okay what does
all that mean
if I want to know the probability across
a branch I simply multiply one of these
by the other and we'll get the
probability for that branch and this is
gonna be really useful to us in a second
that's what this second formula means to
get to the end of the branch I multiply
the first level times the second level
for the branch I care about now a lot of
times when we're given data and we're
going to try and make this really cool
probability tree we're not given all the
data that'll be way too easy so there's
a couple of rules and helpful hints that
allow us to build out a tree first rule
is or the first step we want to take is
try and define the level of the tree in
my black card red card King not King my
definition of levels was okay I could
get a black or red it's a first level I
can get a king or not King I could get a
king or not King and I defined each of
the branches if I have facts go ahead
and fill them in put them down on the
paper I'll show you an example that with
a couple of pictures here in a sec once
I filled in all the facts I know I can
do a little bit of simple math and fill
in a few of the facts I don't know and
then I can start to complete the branch
groups knowing that the probabilities
always add up to one and I can use that
cool formula
then figure out the last remaining
probabilities so let's see how this
works I go out with a bunch of my
friends at work
some of them eat burgers some of them do
not some eat dessert some do not alright
so maybe I want to figure out the
probabilities associated with each of
the branches given that some of the
folks in the company eat burgers or
don't eat burgers eat desserts don't eat
desserts and I'm given three initial
pieces of information the people who eat
burgers two out of every three people
eat burgers given that somebody is not a
burger eater and they eat dessert that
happens in one out of four cases and
given somebody eats burgers and dessert
that happens eight out of fifteen cases
so let's start to fill this in all right
sure probability of eating a burger
given that they don't eat a burger that
you desert and then probability across a
branch they eat burger and dessert so as
I start to fill this in probability eat
a burger is 2/3 probability that they
didn't eat a burger but they dessert is
1/4 and the probability that they had a
burger and dessert was 8:15 we know that
this and this have to equal one so I'm
go ahead and start to fill this in we
know that this and this must equal one
so I fill in the extra value so we're
moving along making good progress one
thing that we're kind of missing is this
guy out here I know this and I know this
and I know if I multiplied this by this
I get that so I can back out and figure
out what this piece is if I know him and
him and that's just algebra and when I
say just algebra some folks suffer with
algebra in high school etc don't panic
just takes a little bit of practice so I
don't mean to say that algebra is crazy
easy all right
so my formula says if I'm trying to
figure out what is the probability of
desert and burger if I know he ate a
burger and we know that he had dessert
and we multiply that by the probability
of burger this doesn't help me because
I'm kind of missing something in the
middle right I'm missing this guy but I
know 8:15 I know 2/3 we can do the
algebra flip this over and put him on
the other side and now when I multiply 8
times 3 and 15 times 2 and I round it
all down I end up getting a 4 out of 5
so I put 4 out of 5 up here and if we
kind of go back and double-check our map
right 2 times 4 is 8 3 times 5 is 15 it
worked out just the way we wanted I know
these two have to add up to 1 so I
figure out what that is now I have all
of the probabilities for every single
branch I know I can multiply this by
that to get here this by that to get
here and there so now I can fill out the
probabilities all the way across the
branch ok so this is useful I now know
that if somebody bought a burger and
they didn't have a dessert that happens
to out of 15 of my friends if somebody
didn't buy a burger and they didn't get
dessert 3 out of 12 of my friends are in
that horrible horrible group where they
don't eat burgers and then only desserts
alright ok so let's do some math here
with our script
here I pulled all the values off that
chart and I started to drop them in here
for branch one probability of burger nut
burger was 2 out of 3 it's a 2 out of 3
1 out of 3 probability of desert not
desert 4 out of 5 1 out of 5 1 out of 4
3 out of 4 and if I add up all of these
it should turn out to be 1 and sure
enough it does all right so I have a
reasonable level of confidence that my
numbers came out the way we expected all
right and this is going to set us up for
a situation a little bit where we can
now move beyond this we can answer some
really interesting questions all right
but for now we'll take a little bit of a
break you guys kind of turn through this
what time does this thing end I always
forget 420 for something 440 sweet so we
have a little bit of time all right so
I'm gonna turn it over to you folks all
right I want you guys to take some of
these pictures I produced for you and
this is gonna mirror exactly what we
just went through you'll have some data
I want you to maybe put on a piece of
paper whatever start to sketch this out
fill in the things that you know start
to fill in the things you don't and then
we'll go from there
meanwhile I'm gonna go back and look at
those there's two functions and figure
out why I suck at math
why did this fail sure you are totally
right
I could swear I changed this because I
saw it I could swear I changed it yeah
that's it I'm good thank you sir so
everybody just fled the room but they
left their laptops which means it's open
season on unattended laptops pick the
ones you want and I'll come back with
your question turn this off
you
you
you
wouldn't I wouldn't give from Microsoft
Paint
all right
so when I first started going down this
road
how many perfectly honest lots of
sweetly lines lots of slashes
parentheses crazy letters and numbers
and things that mean absolutely nothing
yeah my mind exploded it took doing this
multiple times over and over again
reading the topic in book a free reading
the same topic because they didn't
understand it in book B and then maybe
sometimes rereading the same topic in
book C and going ah ha ha ha I see what
you did there right so having said all
of that right if you're trying to go
through things and maybe a drawing
little probability trees and you're like
I don't know what number goes where
you're in good hands half the people in
this room might have been in that very
same same thing and be willing to admit
it there's a bunch of other people in
the room who are in the same boat but
we're not willing to admit it okay in
some of our examples thus far right we
were given things
here's a probability here is a
probability of something happened given
that I have a precursor I have a
condition and then we have the
probability that two things happen this
n is kind of like an intersection of
means and probably guy how to desert
burger and a desert if we picture this
and this just those two for right now
single probability and a probability
with this given symbol in the middle of
it and we scroll back up here when I
just have a probability it goes first
when I have a given it goes second
and so this given probability is up on
this upper branch because it's telling
me this probability of not getting an A
only applies if I'm on the B branch this
probability of getting an A only applies
if I'm on the not be branch so this
given statement helps you figure out
where that particular value fits in any
one of these four things
and then the intersection of hey my
friend ADA Berger and he also or she
also ate a dessert that intersection is
at the end of our chain if I know the
probability ADA burger and I know the
probability I had a dessert given that
they had a burger I can figure out that
intersection so kind of mental model
where these three things fit probability
probability given that I'm on a
particular branch and then the
intersection and so hopefully that will
help you start to flesh out where these
things go but again I read book after
book looked at it multiple ways some
authors are really horrible explaining
stuff some authors are really good some
authors are genius so yep this picture
yes the reason they would equal one is I
have four possible options there's no
other options that my friends could have
it went down they had a burger didn't
have one they had dessert they didn't
have four possible options I have to fit
into one of those four categories and so
the probability of getting any of them
is going to be one and here when I solve
for the probability of branch one branch
to branch three and then I add up all
four probabilities sure enough I get a
one all right so that's that so let's
wrap up this conversation here with this
idea of the law of total probability and
the law of Bayes theorem or base theorem
okay when we looked at those first
probability trees it was fairly easy to
kind of hop from one step to the next
hey my friend had a burger and you know
10% of my friends who ate burgers all
ate desserts it's great but how do I
reverse that question if I'm talking to
a friend and my friend says to me you
know what man
I went to the restaurant I had this
awesome dessert it was crazy good a
little pecan tart how do I figure out
whether my friend ate a burger or didn't
how do I determine the probability of
whether he ate a burger or didn't
because if he says or she says I ate a
dessert I may know this value like my
friend is either on this branch or my
friend is on this branch but I don't
want to pry I would like to just kind of
figure out the likelihood that they ate
a burger how do we get back to that and
that's where the law of total
probability and Bayes theorem come into
play so let's start with looking at the
law of total probability I'm gonna
apologize right there's lots of math
assembly things so again you're gonna
have to go back review this look at this
and kind of work through this I'll blow
this up a little bit to the font is
slightly larger okay so let us presume
that I want to solve the following
problem given that my friend said yep
that dessert was tasty how do I
determine the probability the ADA burger
all right we know that to solve for this
I need to know these two things it's a
formula we had further up on the page
what is the probability of the ADA
burger and dessert divided by the
probability that they ate a dessert we
may look at this and say well Chalmer
already gave us a formula to kind of
figure this out if I want to know what
that is I just need to figure out what's
the probability the ADA dessert given
the head of Burger Times burger that's
exactly what we just did a few minutes
ago so okay
check we can we can solve this it's
going to take a little math but we can
solve that how do I figure out the
probability they had a dessert
so that's something we're gonna have to
kind of figure out okay if I take that
little bit and replace whatever was in
the numerator before okay if I replace
this with this we're gonna make a little
bigger formula but again we kind of know
all of these values here we still don't
know what dessert is quite yet but we're
getting there
we're filling this in with things that
we can answer I can look up the
probability of one of my friends
normally it's burgers and I can figure
out what the probability is today a
dessert if they had a burger to figure
this part out I simply go out to the
ends of each of the branches and I look
at the two branches that say dessert on
them and I say what's the probability
that somebody had a burger and had a
dessert what's probably they didn't have
a burger in the had dessert and just add
those two things together and if I can
add those two together I can get the
overall probability that one of my
friends ate a dessert now the magic
becomes substitute these break them out
a little bit we can solve for what the
probably does a dessert and that is the
law of total probability all right let's
take a quick look at this for a sec
so
knowing what we know we can go through
and do the same process and start to
fill in the little blocks we can start
to multiply things out when you figure
out the probabilities that I received
spam or didn't receive spam
probabilities that there were keywords
in the email or there wasn't keywords in
the email probability that something
went all the way across a branch when
you figure out these numbers at the end
and with all of those things I can go
back to big and I can start to fill in
this part of this this equation I think
you figure out what the probability is
the guy had a dessert okay once you know
that we can take that value probability
they had a dessert replace it with all
this nonsense and now on this side of
the equation I can essentially go and
look at my chart that I sketched out and
I can start to put a number in every
single one of these spots Hey he had a
burger I know what he does how much I
probability had dessert I know the
probability they had burgers these two
guys are exactly the same I know he
didn't have a burger and I know the
probability they had dessert etc so you
can start filling all of those things
and if you can get those six values I
can now tell precisely the odds that my
friend says they had a dessert I know
they had a burger didn't so let's put
this to the test there's a lot of things
going on there let's take a quick look
given that a Spanish style keyword was
found inside of a message what is the
probability that it is classified is not
really being spam right so given a
keyword as president what is the
probability that it's not classified as
spam you say well that seems kind of
weird if there are bad Spanish words in
there doesn't that automatically mean
it's Spanish
not necessarily my friend says hey
Chalmer here's a great book on getting
rich quickly
right he's not spamming me he's sharing
something that he found whereas if I got
an email from somebody you know in a
foreign country hey you want to get rich
quick
maybe that's spam okay so you could have
keywords but the email may not
necessarily be spam all right so I start
off I've got some values we know from
some of the research we've done that
7/10 of the email that comes in is going
to be not spam so I have a number to go
with not spam we know that if something
is on the not spam branch the
probability that a Spanish key word is
there is 1/10 and if we know that or we
can also calculate that given something
is spam and doesn't have any key words
is three out of a hundred things so
let's start to fill in that a little bit
all right so we start to put numbers
down 7/10 of my emails not spam 3/10 of
spam
something was classified as spam but it
didn't have any keywords maybe they're
starting a new spam trend or write only
3 out of 10 things or spam but don't
have any keywords this one is keyword
given the fact that it wasn't spam only
one tenth of the things that aren't spam
have those keywords so now we do all the
things right make sure each of these
branches is equal to one these branches
are equal to one these are equal to one
we back this number out from there and
we start to fill this in all right and
then we do the last bit of the math we
multiply this times that so three times
nine gives me 27 ten times ten gives me
a hundred seven times one gives me seven
ten times 10 gives me hundred fill in
all these all right with every one of
these values filled out like this and
it's as we practice and as we get used
to it it becomes fairly straightforward
to get to this point
guys for the small fun I can essentially
pluck values right off this chart and
start going boom boom boom boom boom
boom boom and I can fill in all six
values and now I can tell you if I got
an email that had some really cool
Spanish key word what's the likelihood
that it really isn't spam all right a
little bit so on the top I say let's go
find out if it isn't spam and there's a
key word present what is that so that is
one out of ten so I put my event size is
one I have ten items if it is not spam
that's a seven out of ten this is a one
out of ten seven out of ten and I fill
in all six of these and there we go if
there is a Spanish key word in my email
inbox get rich quick cialis viagra the
odds that it is not spam in this made-up
example is 20%
and so with Bayes theorem this is a way
to answer questions that might otherwise
seem very difficult to get to my friend
tells me they had a dessert what are the
odds another place where something like
this might be used the beak may be like
a bee testing I give you one version of
a website I give somebody else a
different version of the website when we
get a sense of if they picked something
here what is the chance they were using
this version of the website if they
bought a thing or they clicked on an ad
what is the probability that they were
looking in a particular type of ad so
here's an exercise for you folks I give
you basically the same three types of
data sketch out your little probability
tree start to fill out the tree and so
you have all the values populated and
then much like we did up here go ahead
and work out those six items in the
formula and answer the question
after some of my friends played two
different versions of a board game
talking to my friend the friend said hey
I really want to buy this game what is
the probability that that tester played
version B of the game versus version a
give you guys a few minutes to go
through that give you about seven eight
minutes
all right
okay
the big sticking point here is figure
out what each of these things are just
as I kind of walked around and talked to
a couple people and listened to some of
the comments right the process of
getting from point A to point B is
essentially the hard part and how this
will normally play out in these types of
examples you will potentially be given
one of these two values on a branch so
you have to do the math to get the other
you'll be given two values here and you
can get the third you be given two
values here and you need to get the
middle one those kinds of things and so
as you get practice and you get practice
by doing right you do this over and over
again you will grow accustomed to oh
I've got these three facts or these four
facts and I can start to fill in and
then once you get this down and things
are working out really well then you can
start to apply this to real-world
problems
but once this chart is filled in the
next step becomes take each one of those
things put them into the six spots and
then the math should theoretically work
out all right I'm gonna let you guys
read this section on independent events
and we're gonna move on to lesson three
in the interest of time so you guys can
go back and read that on your own we
want to look really quickly at what we
call discrete probability distributions
and then we want to understand a little
bit about factorials we'll permutations
and combinations and what those are for
and what they mean in the middle of this
we're gonna do a field trip I'm gonna
take you guys out onto the wild wild
internets and we will look at some
things that are out there there might be
of interest in use to you and we'll talk
a little bit about how this you discrete
probability distribution can apply to
other things well let's get started with
the discrete probability distribution
one of the kind of the classic I guess
examples of a discrete probability
distribution is related to slaw
machines by discrete we mean it's broken
up into individual components as opposed
to like a nice curve right with this
slot machine example I have three slot
machine wheels every wheel has certain
symbols on it it might have an apple you
might have an orange and might have a
quarter you might have other random
things depending on how the slot machine
plays out if I were to get an A and a
and a an apple an apple an apple on the
three wheels I get four dollars I had to
pay 20 cents to play so my gain is going
to be three dollars and 80 cents if I
got an apple apple orange they give me
three bucks but again I paid 20 cents to
play so I really only gain two dollars
and 80 cents orange orange orange I get
two dollars I want to highlight this bit
this Apple Apple orange is any order if
I got an apple an orange and an apple
that still qualifies I still get my
three bucks whoo all right they're still
ripping me off okay
now on any given wheel I have a certain
number of oranges I have a certain
number of apples a certain number of
quarters and stuff on that wheel and the
probability of getting an apple is one
in ten the probability of getting an
orange on a single wheel is going to be
2 out of 10 probability getting quarters
2 out of 10 and all the other symbols
the cruft that's 50% probability of
getting some other random symbol okay
what I'm gonna start doing here is I'm
gonna start building out a table of
details we're gonna go kind of step by
step building out the table and it's
gonna take me to a point where I can
figure out what is my average win at the
casino err quoting the word win what is
my average loss at the casino so here
are my wheels here's how much they pay
here's how much I get or how much I pay
so normally when I screw up and I get
nothing none of the wheels helps me I'm
gonna immediately lose 20 cents
if I get 3/4 I get back 80 cents because
I've spent 220 to get there we know the
probability of getting an orange so 2
percent or 20 percent probability of
getting an orange 20 percent probably
getting another one 20 percent
probability getting 1/3 the chances of
me getting 3 oranges in a row is 8 out
of a thousand similarly I can do the
math to figure out what is the
probability of getting all apples that's
one in a thousand probability of getting
all quarters is 8 out of a thousand and
the probability of being a sucker is 997
times out of a thousand I lose cash
straight-up all right if you are a
gambling aficionado please don't be
insulted when I say sucker
that's a colloquialism all right so if I
translate gains and losses we can assign
a probability of getting any specific
gain and here I'm gonna stop calling
them gains and losses I'm going to say X
so I have a capital X and a lowercase X
X is this random variable and the little
X is any individual item and I've only
got four or five options here so out of
these five options that fall into this
big random variable and so I know the
probability of getting any of those five
options and I know how much money I get
and that's gonna help me figure out my
average win or loss all right in our
previous discussions we talked about
averages we use the word mean when we
talk about these distributions we use
the phrase expectation little mood
lighting sweet is somebody leaning on a
light switch all right
it was getting crazy cozy in here
alright so given any particular trial I
might lose I might win is there a way to
figure out my average and that is using
expectation to figure out our
expectation we use a formula much like
we had
before we say all right if I have a
particular X what is the probability
that I'll get that X and then they add
up all of those and that will give me my
mean e x is called expectation but we
also often call it mean so you'll run
into it as both and matter of fact we
might use the symbol for mean which is
this this Greek mu all right so for
starters I multiply the probability
times the the value of the variable and
I get these results a bunch of them come
out positive and then we have this
suckers category which comes out very
negative and if I do all the math and I
add all five of those results up my
average loss every single time I play
this game if I played it a lot of times
when average loss would be 16 cents
every time I play this game all right
sure I might win 4 bucks once in a while
but on average I'll lose 16 cents every
time I play all right now knowing the
mean is kind of cool but we also often
want to know how broad that spectrum is
is there a possibility I might have a
really broad spectrum and maybe I'll get
really lucky on one end of the spectrum
to solve that we essentially solve for
variance right so the variance of any
given probability distribution is the
expectation of the value minus the
average squared all right so let's get
in here this is essentially the same
chart we had before but I take the value
minus the average remember the average
was negative I'm losing money on this so
I subtract a negative value and I get
this once I have taken the average and
subtract it from all five values I'm
gonna have to go back and square it so
we jump in here we take each of those
values we just calculated a second ago
we go ahead and square them all and one
we have a square we multiply it by the
probability and we get all these things
again you go back reread this kind of
absorb it take your time but ultimately
once I've multiplied the square value
times the probability I can get a
variance and I can tell with this
particular data set it's wide it's
narrow things are really close to the
mean a lot of times things are far away
from the mean a lot of times but again
variance is such an ugly number nobody
likes variance so we have standard
deviation and that's just the square
root of the variance all right so your
first question might be holy cow how do
we write code that does all of that well
we're not going to we're gonna skip that
part right and we're gonna go on a field
trip we're gonna look at some libraries
these are your takeaways these are
things you can go home and play with and
explore and consider I'm going to look
at a couple of libraries and figure out
how the pros have put these things
together for our use um the first place
we're gonna start is the stats field
trip and for your reference
don't try to like read out the the URL
because that's that's just gonna like
blind your eyes
all of these are linked at the bottom
and so I have all the URLs to get to
each of these down at the bottom okay so
let's start with the SyFy stats library
blow this up a bit
okay the SyFy library itself has some
tutorials that will kind of walk you
through a series of things certain basic
functions they might have or statistical
functions that are present etc I'm gonna
dive into the SyFy dot stats library I'm
basically gonna kind of scroll through
this and point out a few things the
nuance here that I want you to walk away
with is there's a heck a lot of good
work that's been put into solving some
of these statistical problems that I
should take advantage of instead of
using chalmers crappy code all right we
mentioned a minute ago discrete
probability distributions where things
take certain values they $3 and 80 cent
return a $2 and 80 cent return well
there's other distributions called
continuous and so I'm gonna kind of
scroll through this all right they're
all alphabetical order a so we got alpha
arcs
that these are all continuous
distributions and a lot of work has been
done to try and create these objects in
Python that you can use to look at
distributions of data in various ways
and we'll dive in on one of these in a
few moments but there's a lot right so
we talked about you starting your
statistics journey this is step one this
is the first three hours or something of
a 40-hour college class on intro to
stats and this is you know graduate
level whatever right but there is a
destination you can get to and in many
cases you don't have to go all the way
you don't to know and memorize every one
of these none of us have that memorized
we build on the basics and then when we
need something particular we go and try
and hunt down the thing that will help
us we have what's called multivariate
distributions that look at various types
of multiple variables that correlate
with things we have some discrete
distributions which is what we were
looking at a moment ago and there's
various ways to handle particular types
of discrete distributions and then of
course they've got a whole slew of
statistical functions like mode and
calculating for skew and four variation
and standard deviation etc so let's go
dive in on one of these this is in the
stats library and this is related to a
particular discrete random variable it's
called the binomial discrete random
variable and the way to calculate
certain values that come out of this
they have this really funky formula and
we're not going to spell that out I'll
let you guys figure it out but you
provide it with a couple of values and
it will allow you to build kind of this
body of information that you can then go
and explore and your exploration might
lead you to making graphs that kind of
show patterns in the behavior and if you
want to know specific details about the
data that you could use to make that
graph they have a whole slew of
additional kind of nested functions that
allow you to dig right into that
distribution and understand more about
it etc right I'm not gonna walk you
through all
things but they're there so that's the
first part of the field trip Syfy stats
the next part of the field trip we
mentioned a library called numpy numb
PI's got much like the Syfy library an
incredible set of documentation where
you can start to dive into particular
things that interest you and we're not
going to explore this one the way we did
Syfy stats
pandas also has again kind of this
incredible wealth of information about
how you can calculate information using
the Python statistics library a couple
of us were looking at this a few minutes
ago there's really only about 10 or 12
different types of functions here this
is more the the meat and potatoes kind
of things that you're most regularly and
frequently might use this does not get
into any of the details like Syfy stats
and numpy and stuff will allow you but
it's there and you don't have to import
it you don't have the weight of
importing a lot of things from a
third-party libraries so this is still
useful for the things that show up most
frequently alright so with that so that
was our field trip
I mentioned this idea of these discrete
probability distributions you go home
you start to wrap your head around that
one of the really cool things that you
can do once you have a good
understanding of a discrete probability
distribution is that you can apply what
we call transforms in order to get to
kind of this point I had to multiply
certain things by hey this this is the
probability that something's gonna
happen or this is the gains and the
losses etc well what if my slot machine
owner says hey we're gonna upgrade your
slot machine and it's no longer gonna be
4 bucks if you win this but everything
is gonna be increased by 1/4 you'll earn
4 dollars and a quarter 3 dollars and a
quarter instead of having to go back and
redo this these transforms will allow me
if you guys study up on this to very
simply reevaluate my variances without
having to do a lot of crazy math so
that's pretty cool so you want to
research transforms on discrete
probability functions
so we got 10 minutes I'm gonna walk you
through combinations and permutations
with a sprinkling of factorials if you
recall a few minutes ago I said hey look
at this
if I get an apple an apple and an orange
I'm gonna win something
but I also illuminated the fact that it
really really wasn't just apple apple
orange it was any order of Apple Apple
orange so I can to orange and then an
apple on the second wheel Apple in the
third wheel and when I calculated the
probabilities for this I took that into
account so I got apple apple orange plus
apple orange apple plus orange apple
Apple say that three times quickly this
was easy because there was only three
things I only had like kind of three
combinations of this or three
arrangements of it sorry that's probably
a better term but what if I had lots of
things and I had all sorts of
arrangements is there a way to do that
mathematically and do it easier that's
where factorials combinations and
permutations come into play all right
we'll start off with factorials you
might have seen this button on your
calculator never known what it does
there is often on calculators a button
that'll have something like X with an
exclamation or an N with an exclamation
that represents a factorial what effect
or ially is this simply I will take
whatever number you give me and multiply
it by all the things that are
decremented down by ones so a two
factorial is 2 times 1 a 4 factorial is
4 times 3 times 2 times 1
10 factorial you spelled out it's a nice
way of very simply creating very large
numbers they're composed of things you
might say well what kind of use would
this be let's say that I have 4 books
for example and I want to put them on my
bookshelf and I'm kind of particular
about what order I put them in with the
4 books in my hand I could pick my first
book I have 4 choices and I throw the
first book down
how many choices do I now have left in
my hand I have four books to start with
and I put one on the shelf how many
choices do I have left how many books do
I've left in my hand three so now I pick
one out of the three and I put that on
there how many choices do I have left in
my hand to write so these factorials are
often used in these kind of things we
need to organize and arrange things if I
have a bunch of horses and they're in a
horse race by the way chalmers not a
gambler but yes say I have horses in
there in horse race I have 20 horses
which horse could come first have twenty
options which horse could then come in
second I only have 19 options which
horse could come in third I only have 18
more options right so that's where
factorials come into play a great thing
about factorials is that if I have to do
division of one factorial by another
it's pretty easy because 3 times 2 times
1 over 3 times these cross out and I'm
just left with 5 times 4 so it makes the
math pretty pretty straightforward I've
got a little function here will
calculate this calculate that and so
I'll let you figure out the details of
the function but I've got a function
that will calculate factorials for us I
want to highlight in vivid terms what I
meant by chalmers code sucks and other
code is better by looking at a
real-world solution the calculation of
factorials looks like it's pretty
straightforward but there's a lot going
on to the hood for example if you're on
a 32 bit piece of hardware the size of
an integer maxes out at about 12
factorial if you're on 64-bit hardware
it maxes out around 20 factorial maybe
your computer might want to build or
calculate something larger than that so
you might use floating-point
approximations or representations of
those values and that'll nudge you a
little bit past those points or maybe in
terms of speed you don't want to
calculate 40 times 39 times 38 you might
want to have a lookup table for certain
low-level factorials and then do the
calculations and higher ones or you may
not do want to do the calculations at
all sheep
use an approximation like Sterling's
formula to figure this out so real-world
functions not chalmers will do things to
help improve the speed or the
reliability of it I mean I just want to
show you what we mean by the speed of it
so I created a factorial function we
just looked at it a second ago but there
is actually in pythons math library a
function called factorial and I'm gonna
import it as f so that the two names
don't don't overwrite each other and if
I calculate the factorial of 4 it's
gonna give me back some number and so
let's go look at that make sure we get
something back we get 24 returns 24 is
expected there we go if you've never
used Jupiter to do this it's kind of fun
there is the ability to time certain
statements or expressions etc in in
Python so I'm gonna say use Chalmers
factorial function and calculate 40
factorial and time it and show us how
long it takes to do this and then we'll
use the library in our the function in
the math library and we'll see how well
it works so we'll run that the time it
functions kind of cool it will run this
multiple times and every time it runs it
it will do it some number of times like
a hundred thousand times so it took
about seven microseconds to do it with
Chalmers crappy homegrown code and it
took 300 nanoseconds to do it with legit
code that is really good at this and
optimized for this right that is a
massive difference like a thousand times
difference right something like that or
10 times difference whatever it is math
is not my thing don't trust me for your
maths all right three seconds or three
minutes to go good grief
we'll talk about permutations
combinations and products
with permutations we will look at how we
can arrange things for example how many
ways can I arrange four out of five
books on my shelf I've got five books I
only have room for four let me figure
out which four I want to pick or if I
know that I care about three of the 10
horses that win because I'm gonna bet on
three of them how many different options
are there that three will cross the
finish line right combinations on the
other hand are things where we don't
have to worry about the order of them
with the horses right if if Sally blue
finishes in front of you know Denver Dan
versus Denver Dan finishing first order
was crazy important with that
permutation but with combinations order
doesn't matter what did you have in your
salad I had walnuts I had romaine
lettuce maybe I didn't had iceberg
I had croutons the order doesn't matter
if I said croutons and iceberg lettuce
it doesn't matter
products are a lot like permutations but
you not only care about the order but
you start to replace things so for
example I pull a ball out of a lottery
cage I read the ball I throw the ball
back in and I have the chance of pulling
that same ball out again but the order
of the numbers matters and then
combinations with the replacements it's
the same as combinations but I put stuff
back in the pool so I've got a handy
little chart here do I replace stuff yes
or no
with those books I couldn't replace them
because I only have one copy of each
book with the lottery balls I could put
the lottery ball back in them in the in
the bucket all right order matters order
doesn't matter all right so we can
calculate permutations combinations
products and stuff one thing that I'll
leave you guys with and then we're
pretty much done again rolling your own
not so good there is a library called
itertools that has a function built in
to do each of these and real quick we'll
look I have three things I want to
figure out kind of groupings or
arrangements of them to it
when order doesn't matter I only have
three possible arrangements but if order
does matter did one come before - or did
to come in front of one etc alright I'll
skip all of that there we go
and those are the links to all the
libraries you folks have been amazingly
patient through the day brains are all
fried by now I'm sure I'm glad you came
I appreciate any feedback I will get a
survey link up on the screen here I urge
you to go to this particular location
and give me feedback because feedback is
something that I need so let's see www
dot Survey Monkey dot-com and if I
remember right I think Survey Monkey is
done in Python alright and this is a
capital okay eight two six eight let me
make sure I got this right
surveymonkey.com
/r h gk eight to six eight alright if
you guys need to get ahold of me i've
sent you guys some emails and they have
like my twitter handle in them you can
reach out to me that way my email is
there you can reach out to me if you
want to ask questions please please fill
out the survey that will help me be
better and I appreciate your time
glad you came thank you
[Applause]